The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I was
trying to look at your face
and see whether you
all hate me or not.
And I said I was going to send
an email yesterday and say,
this is the time
for your evaluation.
And then I realized that if
I sent it to you yesterday,
I'd probably gather the
worst evaluation, right?
So I just wanted to remind you,
I'm going to send the email.
You need to do the evaluation.
And sometimes I was--
the other day, I was
telling my wife, I said--
because we always listen
to this, say, Car Talk.
I don't know how many of--
it's a very interesting
radio talk, right?
So at the end, they always say,
we squander an hour with me.
And I say, you squander
a semester with me.
Hopefully-- OK, so we
have three more lectures.
And this is not going to
be a review of the past.
We're going to continue
pushing and see
how much we can stuff there.
What did we talk in
the last lecture--
we focused on the p-n junction.
And then from p-n
junction, solar cell.
In fact, it's very
[? lateral ?] just
to say you got a carrier
generation by photons, which
goes the opposite for the bias.
And then we mentioned the
Shockley-Queisser limit,
where the key is that
the Shockley-Queisser--
in fact, I just had a
program manager call
for two hours in the morning
on the PV project that we have.
And so the Shockley-Queisser
is assuming there's
no other combination other
than, really, the recombination.
And for photons emitted,
say, when the electron calls
not at the equilibrium.
Therefore, there is a
difference in the Fermi level
of the electrons and holes.
And the photon emitted has
a chemical potential, right?
The chemical potential
is the difference
of the [INAUDIBLE] formula was.
So I was presenting some
of the understanding I had
at the end of the last lecture.
This is a very
interesting thinking
from the entropy perspective.
And so with that, we
pretty much finished,
in terms of what I want to do,
a parallel treatment, right?
If you think about--
we talked about molecules.
We talked about electrons.
We talked about phonons.
And we talk about the photons.
And often, we can
treat them more or less
parallel because they
are dilute particles.
And they have wave
characteristics.
And the way that we've
been dealing with this
is we talked about
energy level, that's
due to the wave nature and
the quantization of energy,
due to wave nature
of those matters.
And then we see eventually--
so at a single interface
or model interface,
you have in the first--
you have reflection.
And that's mathematically--
for your approximate interface,
that is zero sickness.
You know that is always smaller
than the wavelengths, right?
So this is what
chapter 5 was about.
And from there, you could
calculate transmission.
So those were a description
under the wave picture.
Then we move on to really the
transition from that wave,
if the wave--
the coherence is lost.
I don't need to
consider the phase
information of those waves.
I just need to consider
trajectory of those waves.
And that's to say, where
it's completed treating
at the particle, right?
So if you think about
quantum mechanics,
what Einstein introduced is
the granularity of waves,
of photons.
Photons, electromagnetic
waves, are granular waves.
So it's a particle
and wave duality.
And the way that
we've been treating it
is, OK, we first try this
either wave propagation
and then eventually,
we completely
enacted a way we treat
them as a particle.
We don't carry the
phase anymore, right?
So there, this is from
the transport perspective.
And then we went to
the Boersma equation.
And using the Boersma
equation, we hopefully
have seen all the diffusion
equations or drift-diffusion
equations in bulk materials.
And then when you
have boundaries
where the boundary creates some
scattering of those particles,
just like when you go play pool.
And then your
particle, your ball,
hits the boundary--
again, reflection, right?
For most of those
[? transport ?] potential,
there's a diffuse
reflection that
create additional impetus
for the carrier flow.
And then chapter 8 was
trying to wrap the idea
that microscopically, when you
think about energy conversion,
it's really the transformation
of one type of energy carrier
energy into another
type of energy.
So that's the interaction, the
scatter and the absorption,
the excitation of
energy carrier.
But at the same time,
you have the loss.
You have the transport.
So you want to design
a good heat engine.
Your thermodynamics
has to be right.
That scatter-- and we
have energy conservation.
We have momentum conservation.
You can think about that as the
thermodynamics has to be right.
And then your transport
has to be right.
I say, that's the left hand
side of the Boersma equation.
And I warn you that I
couldn't do liquid, right?
So if I think about electron,
phonon, photons, or waves
periodic boundary
condition and eigenmode--
and so with that, they
dilute particle approximation
as violet.
And to deal with--
so the next thing
is we're going to
talk about liquids.
And I will spend
only very little time
on the transport
in bulk liquids.
And in fact, I think when
I look at the literature--
I think we don't really
even understand well,
transport in bulk liquids.
And it becomes much harder
because the liquid, as well as
an amorphous material-- you go
to amorphous silicon, right?
You lose that
periodicity, right?
Crystal is an idea because when
you say, give us structure,
you only have one arrangement,
perfect crystal, purity.
But when you say amorphous,
where the atom can be anywhere,
you've got zillions
of arrangement.
So that makes the picture much
[? harder. ?] And the liquid--
so liquid, in fact,
the difference
between amorphous material
and liquid is very small.
And if you think about
glass, you would typically
think of this as a solid.
But the glass, if
you look at people
starting this say,
glassy face, they
have radiological properties.
They could change, all right?
And so first, I gave a
very brief [INAUDIBLE]
for the bulk properties, and
how people try to treat it.
And then quickly, this
field went to computerized,
computer simulations.
And then I'll discuss
more on the interfaces.
In fact, that's probably most
interesting if you deal with
transport-related liquids--
how the liquid interact
with solid at interface,
including the
electrical bubble layers
and the solid, solid
interaction when we have, say,
these interfaces.
So that's chapter 9.
And we're talking about
liquids and the interfaces.
And I mentioned, if
you look at the--
for liquid, what are the
historic approaches, people
trying to deal with the liquid?
One approach is trying to
modify the Boersma equation.
Boersma equation is
a dilute particle.
So when you have a more
concentrated, high pressure
gas, for example, the particle
is a lot longer, very dilute.
So you have the approach.
You modify Boersma equation.
And I'll briefly mention
2-particle distribution--
distribution function, and the
corresponding Enskog equation.
And then the other approach is
really starting with Einstein,
is the Brownian Motion.
And it eventually develops into
the linear response theory.
So those were some
of the directions.
And eventually, this
one didn't pan out.
It's not very fruitful,
Boersma equation.
They tried to modify.
And so most of
the studies now is
based on computer simulation
and linear response theory.
So let's really give a very
brief picture of bulk liquids.
And one of the variables of
the function we use often
to characterize liquid is the
radial distribution function,
which actually can be measured
using tools like a neutron
scattering tool.
And the definition
is, OK, I have--
so this is trying to measure,
what's the order of the atoms?
If I take any of the
atom out of the center,
how are the surrounding atoms
distributed around this atom?
And so the radial
distribution function is 4 pi.
Really, 4 pi ask
r-squared-- the r gives you
the volume around the r.
And this n is the average
density of the atoms.
And this is the
radial distribution.
So basically, if you look in
this radius r, from the atom,
and look at the
thickness of dr--
so how many atoms do I have
in this small shell of volume?
So this is the definition
for the radial distribution
function, so the number of
atoms in r and r plus dr.
And if you think about the
difference between liquid
and gas and the crystals--
typically the radial
distribution function.
So crystal, if I look at the
atom, this is the center.
The next atom is some
distance away, the next layer.
And then the next
layer is periodic.
So you continue.
That's the crystal
periodic arrangement.
And so if this is a g as
a function of r and r--
and if you look at
the gas, the gas
is pretty much like a
uniform distribution.
And so there is
really no structure
in the distribution function.
And then you look at the liquid.
Liquid is to say, if I take an
atom, immediately surrounding
there because of the mutual
influence of the atoms,
there is a little
bit of structure.
And away from it,
there's no correlation
because the atoms are
moving pretty randomly.
So the way I can--
the typical distribution
function of this
is dying off after a
few layers of atoms
surrounding this vessel, any
of the [? space in the ?] atom.
OK, so what's the use, if you
use the radial distribution
function?
For example, I can
calculate, if I
know the potential
interaction between two atoms.
So if I know the potential
interaction between two atoms,
then I can calculate using the
radial distribution function,
what's the total potential
energy in the system?
Is it 0 to infinite
integration, 4 pi r-squared?
And this is a
potential interaction
between two atoms and grdr.
And if you go back to
the thermodynamics--
in chapter 4, we consider the
different partition function,
micro-canonical system,
canonical system,
grand canonical system.
If you write down the
potential energy and you
have kinetic energy.
You have potential energy.
You can actually write down
the distribution functions.
And from the
distribution function,
you can calculate the
corresponding thermodynamic
potential.
A canonical system,
it's the freedom--
free energy there.
And micro-canonical is entropy.
So once you have this
thermodynamic function,
you can derive all the
thermodynamic properties
of the system, like the
equation of states, right?
So one interesting case
was the equation of states.
So for example, if you
say Van der Waals--
this is the famous Van
der Waals potential.
If we take a Van der
Waals potential, phi-r--
the small phi-r, is 4-epsilon
and sigma, or r, 12th power,
minus sigma over r, sixth
power, one rest potential.
And then let's
suppose that I have--
this the radial distribution
function as a step function.
the radial distribution
step is zero.
So it's basically-- here,
I'm drawing this way.
But this step is just here.
This is my d.
So within 0 to d, this
distribution function is 0.
So this is an r
less than d, right?
You can't have atoms
together and closer than d
because that's the territory
of the specific atom.
And when r is larger than d--
let's say this is a 1.
So we lost the
structure completely
once this is getting
out of this region.
So if you take these two
functions, you plug it in.
And what you find out
is that your phi-n
is-- so the total
potential of the system
is an squared over
v, the volume.
And using this potential
energy and kinetic energy,
you go reconstruct the
partition function.
And from partition function,
you get a equation of states.
And equation of states--
the equation of states that
you have is p equals NkBT.
And wave must be n, minus
a squared over v squared.
And the B is the volume for
the individual molecule--
one molecule.
So this is the
equation of states
that's slightly different
from the ideal gas law.
Ideal gas is p
equals nrt, right?
And this is Van der
Waals equation of states.
It comes from the Van der Waals
potential and Van der Waals
equation of states.
And it has a very important
historical importance.
And in fact, if you go to check,
probably the Nobel Prize--
the first one in physics was
in, I think it was the X-ray.
And the first one in
chemistry probably
was one Van der Waals, OK?
And why?
Because if you look
at the ideal gas law,
it's p times [INAUDIBLE]
equals nrt, right?
But the Van der Waals
equation of states
is actually giving
you the liquid.
So part of the
equation of states--
so this is for the Van der
Waals gas, it looks like this--
Van der Waals
equation of states.
And it turns out when you
take a horizontal line,
you create this area.
That's where the
horizontal line should be.
And this is the liquid.
And this is the gas.
And the in between-- so
for different temperatures,
you plot it in between.
You have the vapor dome, right?
So you look at the
steam characteristics.
In this region, you have
mixtures of liquid and steam.
And this is the steam
region, liquid region.
And it turns out, this one--
in between, let's say
this is a, b, c, d.
And the b to c, this
region is impossible.
And in this region, you don't
have a homogeneous state.
You decompose.
So you've got a mixture.
You've got another one phase.
You get water and steam.
And this is the sub-cool you can
potentially have, super heat.
And in between,
some of [INAUDIBLE]
is absolutely unstable.
So you've got mixtures.
And of course,
normally, we always
get those mixtures in the
whole from a to d region.
So the importance of the
Van der Waals equation
really gives you characteristics
from liquid to the vapor phase.
Historically, very important.
So that's the
thermodynamics part.
And from the kinetics part--
so that's a transport, right?
So if you think about
the Boersma equation,
the assumption we have
in the Boersma equation
is the molecular kills, right?
The distribution
function at the end
that we say we can use one
particle in the system,
one particle
distribution function
to represent the distribution
of all particles.
So if I write down a 2-particle
distribution function.
So I type T. One particle has
a position, a momentum, rp.
And second particle has a
position and momentum, r2p2.
That's the 2-particle
distribution.
And the Boersma equation is
based on the molecular chaos
assumption, which means this
is independent of each other--
The trp times the tr2p2.
That's a molecular
kinetic assumption.
And because of
this, the n particle
is just a product of
all those distribution
functions to the n-th power.
And they correct it.
So at the beginning, there
was effort until '60s, OK?
People were trying
to do correction
to this molecular
chaos assumption.
And one of these
is due to Enskog.
And Enskog is still pretty
much like a hot sphere.
And TRP and r2 p2 equals ftrp--
ftr2-- p2.
There is a function-- add
a function to prevent,
for example, the two
molecules or two atoms that
occupy the same location
at the same time.
So you can use that hot sphere.
So here is the function
that represents the distance
of the two molecules.
And with this power
distribution function,
you'll go back to
the derivation.
You start with the
[INAUDIBLE] equation.
And when you simplify
to 2-particle
and you look at your
scattering term,
you derive a set of equations
for f, as well as for g.
What I want to say,
I didn't write.
In fact, I didn't even
write in the book.
It's very complicated equations.
But there were effort--
and in fact, there
are some solutions
to the Enskog equation.
But it was found that
the Enskog equation,
you can do a little bit
denser fluids, not liquid.
Liquid is very dens.
And you can do a denser gas.
But the range cannot
be extended very far.
So because the equation
gets very complicated
and this route of extending
the Boersma equation
was not successful.
It was pretty much
abandoned after 1960's.
So the other direction
came from Einstein.
And Einstein did
a Brownian motion.
And that was his PhD thesis.
He wrote this and went
to the Patent Office.
And they published
all his papers
in 1905, the relativity,
photoelectric effect,
and the Brownian motion.
And so these were by
year publications.
So at the time, he didn't even
there were Brownian experiment.
But he knew a few facts.
And he knew that if you have--
so his purpose was
trying to determine
what's the size
of molecules, OK?
And he knows that
when you have--
so he was doing more
deduction, thinking experiment.
Say, OK, if you have particles,
big molecules, you are solvent.
You put the milk in water.
And the one thing he knew was
that there is an ideal gas law
type for those solute
molecules in the solvent.
And this is the
osmotic pressure.
He knew osmotic pressure.
And so the osmotic pressure, p,
is the same as ideal gas, nrt.
a is the number density
of those molecules
in the air, the solute
molecule in the solvent.
So that's one thing he knew.
And the second thing he knew
was fluid mechanics, OK?
And Einstein knew that
when you have a particle,
and in fluid flow, you have--
of course, this is a
very small particle.
And the Stokes drag.
When a particle moves in the
liquid, there's drag flow--
drag effect.
So the drag force--
does anybody remember
the drag force?
AUDIENCE: 6 pi mu D.
PROFESSOR: OK, 6 pi mu
de D. Well, is it D or R?
OK, I have 3 pi--
AUDIENCE: It's mu R.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
it should be R, right?
OK.
R times velocity,
Stokes's formula.
And he uses this
to construct the--
what's the diffusion mass flux?
So you can do this by saying,
OK, I have osmotic pressure.
If I have a
concentration gradient,
I have a pressure gradient.
So a is the concentration.
So if, let's say,
in the x direction,
there's a
concentration gradient.
You take a control volume.
And you do your pressure.
So px minus px plus dx.
And I should say, this
pressure at the steady state
[? through ?] the balance of
the drag force on the particle.
Due to the osmotic pressure,
the particles are moving.
And the resistance
on this particle
is due to the Stokes
flow, drag force.
So what you have here is times--
let's say here.
This is a pressure
times the cross section.
Let's say here is your cross
section we're considering--
and minus 3 pi mu
D. I don't use R.
And u times the number of
particles in this volume.
That gives me steady state,
pressure-driven force,
and resistance due to the flow.
And if you write it
into differential form,
what you have--
because AC times, eventually,
dx, gives me volume.
[? dvA, ?] [? dN ?] and
[? dA ?] gives me another N.
So I will have--
what you get out of this is
n times u equals minus one
third, 3 D mu, dp, dx.
And dp/dx, when you convert it
into using the osmotic pressure
relation, we have kBT
and 3 pi D mu and dn/dx.
So this is the flux.
If you look at this, number
density times velocity
gives you the flux
meter squared,
the number of particles
per meter square.
So what we have
here, essentially,
if you think about
Fick's law, this
is your j flux equals
minus a, dn/dx.
That's the diffusivity.
And here, the diffusivity
is related to the viscosity
diameter, right?
So from here, you can say the
diffusivity is a kBT and a 3 pi
D mu.
So from here, Einstein says
you can do an experiment.
Your drop of milk--
you measure diffusivity.
Time it, and you
can visibly see it.
You know the viscosity.
This the viscosity
of the liquid.
You know that.
You know what's the
diameter of the molecule.
So it's very simple, right?
And so that's why this is
called the Einstein relation.
Recall when we talked
about semiconductors,
the semiconductor
has a diffusivity.
And the mobility has a relation.
And here is
diffusivity viscosity.
Viscosity is also--
so in the term,
mobility is, like,
an inverse mobility.
This is a diffusion
process, right?
So diffusion is
due to fluctuation.
Viscosity is a sort of
friction dissipation.
So this is one example of the
more generalized fluctuation
dissipation theory.
Here we have fluctuation.
Here we have dissipation
All right, OK,
so that was Einstein treatment.
And in fact, Einstein later
on solved the other way.
So if you do nano fluids, you
go to read the Einstein paper,
he actually saw, this
is one way to do this.
And he'd say, OK, you
can also add a nanopart--
I called it nanoparticle--
those molecules.
And you measure
viscosity increase.
So what's the viscosity increase
to the base fluid viscosity?
And from there, he had another
way to do the same problem.
So for that problem, he
actually has to solve--
he actually solved the viscosity
flow problem around particles.
So you can say he's
a fluid mechanician.
We didn't go to the other
research, fluid mechanics.
OK, so that was
the starting point.
There was a very small book on
the Einstein work in this area,
on the Brownian motion--
and very cheap, $10.
You should go to get
take a look at it.
And so from here, there
was the generalization.
So Einstein had said the
lesser generalization
is due to Langevin equation.
And the Langevin equation
is a stochastic question.
Just say, OK, is F=ma?
But the driving force is due
to random thermal fluctuation.
So if you write the--
if you have, say, a particle
in the liquid and surrounding
fluids, give a kick, random.
And then this says you have,
then, the acceleration,
ma, the d velocity, dt.
And the force acting on the
molecule or atom or particle,
when you start moving, you
always have a drag force.
So the drag force
is always there.
And drag force is
proportional to velocity.
OK, you can write into
normalized to mass.
But say it's
proportional to velocity.
So you can do a vector--
put a vector.
So there is always drag force.
And then you have
random kicking force,
random force, the fluctuating.
So that's the random
driving force.
Here is random.
And there's some basic relation
because there's a random force.
So the average is 0--
itself is 0.
And this random force
is not related to r.
So if you do your time
average, they are also 0.
But the driving force
itself, of course,
is related to temperature.
So if you say here is
the different time, r--
at the time, s.
And the typical
Langevin equation
assumes this is instantaneous.
So there is no memory.
And here, what we have is
2 m eta kBT, and delta, t.
Delta t is just to
say instantaneous.
And this random fluctuation
is related to temperature
and also related to how large
is the dissipation here.
OK, so this is the
Langevin equation.
And solving this little
Langevin equation-- because this
is random.
So actually it could be pretty--
you go through rigorous math.
There are many different
ways to solve this random.
You can do a spectral
analysis, for example.
But in the book, I'm
not going to present
going through every step, we
have a very non-rigorous way,
just to say, I multiply both
sides because this one du/dt,
can be written as d/dt, dr/dt.
So if I multiply both
sides by r and you
go take the time average,
this term actually drops out.
So you get a regular
equation you can solve--
an ordinary differential
equation, so you
can solve for the radius--
the radius of the
particle from t equals 0.
So here, I'm going to
give you the results.
So if you do the radius
of this, r square,
this is where, if you put a
particle here, after some time,
where it's going to be.
And this is the random walk.
And the radius is 6 KBT, m eta,
and then t minus 1 over eta,
and plus eta
exponential minus eta t.
So this is the solution for
the distance from the origin
[? built ?] to the random
walk of this particle.
And you notice, there
is this long time--
this term drops out, right?
So the diffusion, the distance--
because this is
related to diffusivity.
So the distance will
be really, diffusivity
times the time square root.
That's the order of magnitude
of the diffusion is.
This is when you saw the
Fourier law of heat conduction,
you know the diffusion of
heat is diffusivity times
time, square root.
So that's the long time
behavior of the Brownian motion.
So the heat conduction,
all this diffusion,
is a random walk process.
And recently, if you
check the literature,
there are actually a lot
of people still doing
the Brownian motion experiment.
And some people say,
we did the experiment.
We say the initial term also.
That's the translating at
the start of the kicking.
So one interesting
comment I have here
is if you look at the Brownian
motion, look at the velocity
here, forget about this.
You see the velocity
will be exponential decay
because this is the velocity.
This is velocity.
If you solve velocity, this
is exponential decay after.
It's getting quickened, right?
So all this relation
comes from--
related to the
exponential decay.
But it turns out this is wrong.
And the reason for this is wrong
is in this Langevin equation,
there is also--
when your molecules get a kick--
here you use the
Stokes theorem--
Stokes drag.
But when a particle
starts from 0,
this is a steady state solution.
And when a particle
starts from 0,
stationary, gets a kick, you
get a transient solution.
And that transient term--
what's significant, if you add
a transient term into here,
there should be additional
transient term, the Stokes
force.
And that transient
term is integral.
So it depends on
the previous time.
So this equation actually
becomes an integral equation--
differential integral equation.
And if you solve this
differential integral equation,
you don't get the exponential
decay for velocity.
You get a power law
for the velocity.
So if you saw,
velocity is actually,
if you solve this
transient, is t--
remember, it's
1.53, three halves.
So it's a very slow decay.
Exponential and power are
very different, right?
Exponential is a very fast.
Power is slow.
So that's the memory, in fact,
of the Langevin equation.
And I was interested
in this because--
so the discovery of this
memory effect was by computer.
So in 1950 or 1960,
when people started
doing the computer simulation,
molecular symbolism,
molecular dynamics,
they found this is not
the case with velocity,
all the correlations.
So typically, you calculate.
Turns out later on, when we we
go to linear response theory,
you see that
diffusivity is related
to velocity autocorrelation.
So it's ut u0, dt.
So that's a velocity
autocorrelation function,
right?
So you can see, if
it's a power decay,
you would expect that
this is very different.
Was Einstein's original
relation between diffusivity
and mobility wrong or not?
It turns out that even though
he didn't [? include, ?]
even though he has
an exponential decay,
but the autocorrelation, at the
end, the result was the same.
So he was lucky.
They determined the fluctuation
dissipation relations
still valid.
Even the decay function
is very different.
And this was later proven.
There was a paper later
proven mathematically
by some integral
differential equation
that said this is still valid.
So I was interested
in this problem
because for a long
period, people
are doing this with nanofluids.
They added nanofluids
in the liquid.
They say there's higher
cerebral connectivity.
And their theories say they're
Brownian motion, whether it's
a Brownian motion, in fact.
And Brownian motion, if you
do this exponential decay,
it drops very, very rapidly.
And you go to do all the
automatic things-- about five,
six automatic-- too small
to actually contribute
to heat conduction.
Then there are other people
at the same time-- we actually
found the paper that said, oh,
this is a much slower decay.
And because there's
a power law, and that
may be explaining the
strong connectivity
is not exponential.
And then they went further.
And they say, OK, it
turns out that people
prove at least for viscosity
and diffusivity, that's
a fluid flow problem.
It's still valid.
So then the question is for
heat transfer, for energy,
is that valid or not?
It's an unanswerable
question, OK?
Later on, we did an experiment.
And we don't think
it's a Brownian motion.
But mathematically, that's
still one thing in my mind,
is what is the autocorrelation
function for heat
and how they decay
in a Brownian fluids.
And when you consider
this time retardation,
the memory effect, what
people call memory effect
because it takes time for
the Stokes flow to kick in.
OK, so that's all I'm going to
talk about for the bulk fluids.
And I think that
there are actually
really a lot of very
poor understanding,
even on the basics, of
transport in liquid.
And there is some potential to
do good research in this area.
And next, what are
we moving on is going
to talk about the interfaces.
So what's important
is to understand
the potential interaction.
And so let's look at the
forces and the potentials.
And of course, we know force
is the gradient of potential.
So if I know the potential,
I know the force.
And what we're looking at is
more longer range potential,
so due to the charge.
We're not looking at
the covalent force
between that typically connects
the atoms to form molecules.
So when we look at the longer
range potential due to charge,
you can always start
the most basic.
So let's do, of course, the
most basic Coulomb force--
Coulomb interaction.
We'll have a positive
charge, a negative charge.
I have this is as
a Q1, this as a Q2,
and the potential as Q1,
Q2, and 4 pi epsilon r.
r is the separation
between the two.
Here is the r.
And you can use the
basic Coulomb potential
to construct all other forces
that, due to elect, let's say,
this charge or region, due
to this Coulomb origin here.
And so for example,
I want to understand
what's the potential
between a single charge, Q,
and the dipole.
A dipole is a positive
and negative charge
very close to each other.
So I'm going to have a dipole
here of positive and negative
charge.
And here is minus Q. Here is
a plus Q. And let's say here
is A. And the distance
of the dipole here is d.
And the separation--
the dipole-- this d
is much smaller than the
radius, the separation between q
and the dipole, that's
r. r is larger than d.
So you could then just sum up
all those Coulomb potential.
What's my potential here, is
the potential is equal to Q--
to this Q or to this Q here.
And this is a b.
This is a c.
So if I write the 4
pi [INAUDIBLE] AB,
so to the negative charge, plus
this Q to positive charge--
4 pi epsilon, to AB.
So I have a AC.
So you just write
the distance down.
And do your math, using
the fact that the--
so, here if I do
the AB, for example,
is r minus d over 2 cosine theta
squared, plus d sine theta,
d over 2 squared.
So that's my-- the
orientation of this dipole.
This is a theta.
D-- so it's a 1/2 d.
That's this distance,
times sine theta.
That's this one.
And then minus-- that's
because on this side.
And that's the distance, AB.
It's just the hypotenuse
of the right triangle
when I'm writing down.
And similarly, you can write AC.
And then you use the fact
that r is much larger than D.
You linearize it.
And what you have here--
I have minus Q. Theta is a
dipole moment, cosine theta,
and 4 pi epsilon r squared.
I'll say beta is the dipole
moment is the Q times D.
So now, this is in my potential
originally for a single.
You can say for
two point charge,
I have the potential
is 1 over r.
So the force is
1 over r squared.
Now if I look at
the point charge in,
dipole the potential
is over r squared.
And the force is
over r cubic, right?
Because you want to know
what are those relations?
And as another example,
I want to find out,
what's the forced interaction
between two solid surfaces?
Why I'm interested in that?
Because I want to say, if
I put a particle in liquid,
what do they-- what is the
attraction force, whether I can
keep this fluid stable or not?
If they glue onto
each other, you
have, eventually, sedimentation.
How can I make a
stable [? column? ?]
You need to know those forces.
So I have constructed, using
the simple Coulomb potential,
between--
a point charge and dipole.
I can look at the
last what I have,
when I look at
the dipole-dipole.
So if you look at two dipoles,
due to the Coulomb interaction,
because you have--
the dipole has a
positive or negative.
Each one has a
positive and negative.
You interacted
with the other one.
You got the full term summation.
And then you add up
all those four terms.
And you find out that your
potential for dipole dipole
due to this is r-6, right?
When we talk about Van
der Waals potential,
this is the attractive part.
And then when they
get very close,
you got the repulsive part.
Here we're talking about
the attractive half, OK?
And with this, you can-- so
this is a two isolated dipole.
Now, with this dipole,
you can go construct.
If I have a dipole and I have
a solid, what's the force?
What's the attraction between
this dipole and this solid?
The solid itself, I'm going
to consider not a solid that's
made up for--
not a single point charge solid.
I say it's neutral.
Each atom is neutral.
Then I can approximate that
atom itself as a dipole.
So really, each point
that I have dipole,
I'm going to sum up the first
interaction of this dipole
with all the dipoles
in the solid.
So if you do that-- so here,
I have the distance, d.
And let's say, here, I
have my [INAUDIBLE],, the x.
And because of axis symmetry,
I can consider any x I do--
I say when I integrate
or, say, infinite.
If I consider either
any x radial direction,
so this is like I have a
cylindrical coordinate.
And I can write the potential
interaction between this dipole
and the ring here as--
because it says the
distance is the sixth power.
So the distance here,
if I look at this point,
and this is the r,
here I have D plus x.
So I have a D plus x
squared, plus r squared,
and sixth power.
So this is my distance.
And then I have the lumbar
density of this dipole atoms,
and 2 pi rdr--
that's how many I have--
and then times dx.
So that's the volume.
And so dx-- and then
I integrate-- the x
is 0 to infinite.
This is my origin,
0 to infinite.
That's x.
R, I zero to infinite.
The order is solid.
So you do that.
What do you get?
You do your integration.
You get the-- this is a
pi n, and a 6 D cubic.
So D is the separation between
this dipole and the wall--
and the solid.
And that's a potential.
If I do it once I
have the potential,
I take the derivative.
So the force is a D force power.
OK, now if you go to
check in the book,
I give example
because people say,
do I have a slip when I have a
liquid flow on a solid surface?
So I use this.
That represents my own opinion.
I said there is no slip
in the normal condition
because I'm just saying, when
I have this dipole, what's
the bonding force?
And then I look at it and
say, I have the atoms.
And what's the potential
barrier on the surface?
And the question is whether
I have enough shear force
to [INAUDIBLE] those
potential barriers.
So I guess my point is
that you can take that.
You can criticize it.
But the point is, you can
develop your own argument.
And then you let others
shoot it up and say,
where is wrong here?
And of course, if you have very
large shear, you may have it.
But in a practical
situation, I don't
think there is a [? slate ?]
between liquid and solid
surface.
OK, so this is one
dipole to a all solid.
And now I can do the same if
I have two pieces of solid
to a parallel plate.
So I have two parallel
plates separated by D.
And if both sides are dipoles--
and again, now you already
integrated one side.
You just integrated
this other side also.
In that case, what
you have is a phi
equals minus A 12 pi D squared.
And this A is pi squared
c, and n 1 times n 2.
The n 1, n 2 are the number
densities on both sides.
And this A is called
the Hamaker constant.
How many of you have
heard of Hamaker constant?
That's where it comes from.
And so now, this
is the potential.
So what's the forced interaction
between two parallel plates?
Van der Waals force,
that's D squared--
D cubed, right?
For two atoms, you do D
6, potential D 7 force.
And for two parallel
surfaces, it's D cubic.
You can do spheres also--
different geometry.
And in fact, you read the books,
people have done all those.
So with a different surface,
there is a corresponding--
that integration gives you
different Hamaker constant.
And by the way, this was
considered-- this a classic.
There's nothing
really complicated.
You can do that.
You go back and you
redo it yourself.
But that was in--
I think it was in
1940's or 1950's.
The same problem was to
put a different spin.
And this was a suggestion
by Max Born to Casimir--
Casimir again, right?
So we said Casimir did this size
effect on thermal conductivity.
And Max Born suggests
to Kashmir, said,
this Van der Waals force
can be understood also
as a zero-point energy.
So then Casimir went back.
What he did is, OK, if you
have-- this is the other way
to look at this force.
And in this case, there's
no longer electrostatic.
Here is the electrostatic.
It's Coulomb force, right?
But this other way to
understand it is like the mode.
The energy of electromagnetic
waves stay in this gap, right?
And so this is the mode.
And there are many other modes.
If you think about it, it's the
perfect reflecting surfaces.
As you move closer
and closer, there
are more modes
that are excluded.
So the energy in this
cavity is smaller.
So if you know the
energy, again, you
take a derivative
of this energy.
You get the force.
And this mode is
zero-point because one half
hu, that's the energy.
That's zero-point
energy in the cavity.
And it's the other
interpretation
for the Van der Waals force.
So let's now give you
a quantum picture.
It's important because now, if
you look at the lots of work
on Casimir force.
But this one, of course,
is electrostatic.
So this picture
So the mode is more getting
into the dynamics, right?
So later on, there are further
developments by Lifshitz.
The [INAUDIBLE] Lifshitz,
the Lifshitz book.
And he developed a
theory based on just
the electromagnetic wave.
You really calculate
using dielectric functions
of median 1, 2, 3.
So what we have here is
the electrostatic limit.
But if you do
electrodynamics, you
can have a generalized theory.
And that generalized
theory, it turns out,
depends on the dielectric
constant of the epsilon 2.
Here, we are talking about
Van der Waals is attractive.
This tool actually, if
you have another media,
right media in between, you
can actually have a repulsive.
The two surfaces can
actually repel each other.
So some people are trying
to develop that in the MIT
campus-- a lot of
faculty, several faculty,
Steve Johnson and
I think Carter--
[INAUDIBLE] Carter, and several
people are working on this.
So the idea is, can
you develop a surface
if there's no friction--
if you can repel
those self-repelling.
OK, so with this, we have talked
about the attractive forces,
right?
And like I said, if
I want to look at--
I put a particle in
fluids, and if there
are only attractive forces,
they will agglomerate
and sediment, right?
And you need a repulsive
force to maintain them,
if you want to have equilibrium.
You can keep this
a certain distance.
So in the next lecture,
we're talking about that.
But I want to go back
to the solar cell.
I want to show you a few
slides on solar cell.
I didn't have time last lecture.
OK, so I didn't show any
of these graphs last time.
We talk about basic principles.
So here is Shockley-Queisser
limit calculation
for the maximum efficiency
of a solar cell.
And it depends on the
band gap of the material.
So here, you can see this
is the concentration.
If there's no active
concentration, you get the--
this is about 1.4.
That's the peak.
And the peak efficiency
is about 23, 20.
That depends on what kind
of spectrum you take.
And the original
Shockley is about 28.
And this is about 31, 32.
So this was a paper
by [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is about a
gallium arsenide band gap.
1.1, this here, that's silicone.
So silicone and gallium arsenide
are in the good band gap range.
And here is the efficiency.
If you concentrate
this 1,000 times,
by concentration, you
generate more photons.
If you look at it, then you have
larger open circuit voltage,
and also higher short
circuit current.
So you get the
higher efficiency.
And that's a single junction.
And here was some historical--
it's an old one, you can see.
And the silicone-- the
best crystalline silicon,
that's this line here.
And I actually with
the [INAUDIBLE],,
the group before, they say
they have about 26% efficiency.
And so actually, this is
a single junction cell.
Single junction cell is the
best with Shockley-Queisser.
I'd say about 30, 31%.
So that's actually
getting pretty close.
And what's interesting here
is the multi-junction cell.
The multi-junction cell now
is about 41, 42% efficiency--
43?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] 43.
PROFESSOR: Huh?
PROFESSOR: OK.
43, they split--
that's by wavelength,
split into different cells.
That's another one.
AUDIENCE: One.
PROFESSOR: It's one?
OK.
But see, I think here, this
one is the cad telluride.
That's the first solar.
It's a lower efficiency.
It's a direct gap solar cell.
And the first solar, cadmium
telluride, you almost
get the worst in the world.
But they are most
profitable company.
Because cadmium is a poison.
It's toxic, environmentally.
And you go to Japan, they
had an environmental disaster
in the 60s.
They never touch cadmium.
But first solar,
they use a thin film.
Their film is a few microns
because the optical absorption
is a good direct gap.
And they are selling about 11%--
10% to 11% efficiency.
The silicon cell is
[INAUDIBLE] anywhere.
This is lab efficient.
That's the best efficiency.
Silicon cell is selling
anywhere between 15% and 18%
or 20% efficiency.
So at the end, there
is a cost because they
are the most profitable
because the silicon is about--
a few years ago, $3.
So now it's-- this cost
curve is dropping very fast.
And a lot of work is done
on the polymer solar cell.
And you see the history there.
And this should be the diesel.
It's an open circle.
That's the diesel.
And that's what-- it should
be around 11% [INAUDIBLE]..
But see, eventually,
which one is going to win?
Which one goes first
to get the grid parity?
Grid parity means it can compete
with coals and natural gas.
It's very cost sensitive.
Multi-junction cells is trying
to use different spectrum
of the wavelengths.
And it's actually
really quite ingenious,
in the sense you have a wider
gap semiconductor on top.
So the red light
doesn't get absorbed,
go through [INAUDIBLE]
on the bottom.
But you have to
connect them correctly.
Each cell has to generate--
because you're not putting
the cell in series, right?
The top cell generates
a certain current
that goes to the next cell.
So the current has to match.
And also, typically
when people connect,
they do quantum
tunneling-- tunnel junction
to connect them.
So if you make an
infinite junction,
practically, people
[INAUDIBLE] junctions
because when you grow
different materials,
they become very crabby.
And once mature becomes
crabby, it doesn't work.
Recombination is too fast.
But theoretically, if
you do infinite junction,
you can get around
86% efficiency.
And recombination,
we already mentioned.
So this is where the silicon
is very good, abundant.
This optimal absorption,
that's really not good.
That's the problem.
See, [INAUDIBLE] the cost.
So you need the thicker one
to get the absorption up.
And that's related to
materials because you have
to use very pure materials.
So this is the single
crystalline and
polycrystalline.
If you go out, you look
at this, that's your--
you pretend you're an
expert, whether you
have a polycrystalline.
Look at this-- colorful.
That's poly.
That looks like a
more monocrystalline.
And then people are
trying to do thin film,
for example, amorphous silicone.
With amorphous silicone,
the problem is the mobility.
Charge does not
travel very well.
So even though you can use a
500 nanometer amorphous silicon,
it's still too thick
for electron holes.
So you want to make
it even thinner.
And once you get a very
thin, the optical absorption
is also a problem.
And here, people have
actually tried to make--
you can see here.
You have amorphous silicon.
That's the widest band gap.
And then you have
microcrystalline silicon,
or you can have silicon
germanium with a different band
gap, so that you can
multi-junction cells.
This is a polymer.
Polymer, unlike the
typical pin junction,
where you got a potential--
in fact, the potential
is not that important.
Just by diffusion you find
the concentration gradient.
And the polymer problem
is the molecular chain.
You excite the electron hole.
The problem is that
the electron hole,
they're bound to each other.
So they actually
have a lower energy.
That's acetone.
And what you want is
to extract them out.
The electron goes one side,
hole goes to the other side.
But acetone, if they bind
to each other, eventually
they die.
They release heat.
You're doomed, right?
So first you need to
separate the acetone.
And then get it
onto the polymer.
Again, the conductivity
is not good.
So people are doing this
three dimensionally.
One is a hole conductor.
The other is an electron
conductor that's
bulk junction solar cells.
Even though when I
say bulk junction,
it means that it's a
penetrating junctions, PM,
[INAUDIBLE] materials.
And also, you have
to make it very thin.
And Gratzel cell,
electrochemical cell--
they use, really, molecules,
their dye, as the synthesizer.
And it's a monolayer.
So they coat them, every
nanoparticle, with monolayer,
to increase absorption.
Again, you get the
electron hole, the acetone.
And once you get that,
because it's a monolayer,
so you generate
the electron hole.
And one goes to the solid.
That's the titanium oxide.
Titanium oxide is in cosmetics.
So it's pretty cheap.
And the hole goes to the liquid.
So the liquid
oxidizes and diffuses
through the electrode--
and then reduced.
And so this is where,
because it's a liquid,
it's not very reliable.
And the reliability
is a big problem.
And so people say
this could be cheap.
But so far, nobody has been
able to commercialize them.
OK, so that's what
people are trying to do.
OK, so here is a first gen,
silicon-based, thin film-based,
whatever solar you can try
to get a lower efficiency--
higher efficient, low cost.
There's a lot of
people working on this.
OK, stop here.
And just a reminder,
I'll send you an email.
Now you can vent all your angry.